you want to know a little about early  days  pony express riding was the toughest  work in the bunch  if you were scouting you could go where  you pleased  but if when you was riding pony express  you had a trail to go  and on that trail you couldn't move  you changed horses about every 20-25  miles  sometimes you didn't change at all  because you couldn't  your station was taken up  [Music]  then there was times when you had to  shoot  and the way we done it was this way  that's all it got  [Music]  and you asked a little about this this  is how we've done it  [Music]  one of the toughest things with phony  express lighting if you were scouting  you could go where you pleased  but huh  all kinds of weather and  when the streams are up you have to swim  them  but the mail goes through just the same  [Music]  you